on vous l'annonçait hier le centre LGBTI
de Touraine a été vandalisée à nouveau
dans l'après-midi du 22 mai cibler par
un projectile d'étonnant une sixième
agression depuis le début de l'année
encore plus violente que les précédentes
heureusement seuls des dégâts matériels
sont à déplorer clémencedosc
la bouteille
du coup on n'a pas nettoyé encore donc
il y a les restes
des traces de l'attaque il ne reste pas
grand chose le contenu de la bouteille
rempli d'aluminium et d'un liquide
encore inconnu ont été emportés par la
police scientifique survenu hier vers
15h30 cet acte de malveillance n'a fait
aucun blessé parmi les salariés le
bénévole présent la détonation a eu lieu
alors que ces derniers s'étaient
précipités dehors à la poursuite de
l'individu masqué un jeune homme qui
était sur la droite qui était en train
de remettre ses affaires dans un sac il
a mis son sac sur son épaule et il s'est
retourné en disant bon courage et il est
parti en courant un nouveau palier de
violence franchie avec cette sixième
attaque du centre LGBTI depuis le début
de l'année pitre brisé tentative
d'intrusion boîte aux lettres
vandalisées ce sont désormais des
personnes qui ont été visées une
tentative d'intimidation qui n'arrête
pas les salariés et bénévoles dans leur
mission il y a rien à qui
dans la défense des droits LGBT
il faut continuer il faut surtout pas se
laisser intimider une plainte a été
déposée les témoins ont été entendus par
les forces de l'ordre la préfecture a
annoncé un renforcement des patrouilles
aux alentours du local en attendant sa
sécurisation